Italia se prepara al inicio de un nuevo
ejecutivo este viernes el presidente de
la república italiana Sergio matarella
encargó la formación de un nuevo
gobierno a Georgia melón y la líder del
partido de ultraderecha postfascista
hermanos de Italia quien presentó
inmediatamente al jefe del Estado
italiano su lista de ministros un
gabinete es de 24 ministros 18 hombres y
seis mujeres entre ellos Antonio tayán y
ex presidente del parlamento europeo
quien ha sido nombrado canciller y Vice
Primer Ministro también
Mateo salvín y el líder del partido de
ultraderecha en la liga ha sido nombrado
vicepre Primer Ministro y ministro de
infraestructuras por otro lado Joan
Carlo georgetti ministro de economía Un
gobierno que marcará sin duda una página
histórica en la política italiana ya que
Georgia melón y se convertirá en la
primera mujer al poder en Italia y se
tratara del gobierno
derechista desde el nacimiento de la
República Italiana la ceremonia de
juramento de el nuevo gobierno se
llevará a cabo este sábado en la mañana